Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Sheltered.
Now there is a lot of you guys that actually
wanted to see more of this game...
And I'm more than happy to do so
I just can't promise
that I am gonna be, any sort of good
or that the Ipliers are actually gonna survive
Which contrary to the name (events?) of the last episode of the series...
"GASP" (Inhale)
It may or may not happen
Wake the FRICK up, answer the goddamn radio
Wait... (*sudden realization*)
ARRRGGGHHHH (This may or may have not caused a couple orgasms. *Wh- no...*)
God damnit,  I've already missed it!
I just got back!
Goddamni-(Sudden realization)-Why is the bed at 54% integrity?
How hard, you, assholes have been sleeping on it, D-ok.
So while these guys are in their bagsJ?
We got Barbra(?) down there.
We got David up-here.
Steven and...
(Father of the year)
OH God what is their name?
I can't even remember the name of my daughter! (Mark is gonna be a great dad!:D)
(JUMP) So he is drinking
And he is, OK.
So
What i've done is that i've set-up Autonomy(independence or freedom) for these guys
Since the last episode, which means
That the-gna  generally take care of their need as...
They can get to them.
But the problem is that I'm running out of FOOOOOODDDDD
And i am running out of FFUUUEEELLL
And i am getting a lot of water which is a good thing...
Because that means that SHHEEEE, or HEEE
(Attention Wavers)
I don't think  he need to fix it
so we should be able to get water
YEEEAHH
That's why i've got all these water butts...
To be able to get enough water, but what we need now is food.
And lots of it
And Damn-it, i missed their expedition thing which probably means that they had an opportunity to get god-damn food.
We're gonna have to cut up Spike(the dead horse)
(Which you didn't feed.)
And eat his corpse
(Every food is good when you don't personally know it.)
Ahhh is horrible (tears emerge) Oh god Spike, i am so sorry Spike
I had no idea, Spike
I am so sorry (serious)
I meant to  do good.
By everybody but i am very new!
It's like where i first started Subnautica®.
I don't have a god-damn clue of what i am suppose to be doing
Ahh let's put that away for now.
All' right, so DaviD can you (Exhale)
Oh man, is there like an upgrade to the food? (No)
Can we make an upgrade to the Food?
Oh, god-damnit, ok.
So they got plenty of locati-(Attention Shifts)
OHHHH they did get food.
UHHHHHHHHHHHH
They did get food, i forgot about that.
Did they already come back  in the last on- Thn(Then)The save-game came before that?
I can't exactly remember (Neither do i)
Ok, but we need.
K-We need to craft more food storage, because we don't have enough
Wat?
OHHH god-damnit, nails?!?!
Ahh shit, kids  looks like you're gonna have to go back out there, again.
I am sorry, itzz (it's) the only way.
(Jump) oh shit.
Graahg. (Who is there?)
Wo(Who) es (is),dere (There)?
Ahh ok.
What's going on?
Ehh all right it's fine
WHo's ThErE? Ok.
(Jump)
All'right but at least, let's see, Marie.
Are you doing relatively ok?
(Jump)
All right, so DaviD, what is this, there is something on the Journal
(Read the damn Journal)
(Do you know how much effort i put into this?!?!)
Aww man, (Getting Sassy) well that's saadddd, i mean it's the whole end of the world so what do you care about retirement, let's get to Tomorrow
A'll right, whatever, Marie.
Youuu need tooo ... get an expedition going.
AAAhhh Bar bara
A'ri-Let's get DaviD
Let's get DaviD and Marie
Good father daughter time going on here. (10/10 Mark best father...)
Ahhh all right, so we need to go to multiple locations, we haven't been nearly enough
And (Attention Shifts) Holly shit, there is a lot of stuff out there, ok.
So we need to go to- This Petrol Station- This Small House- This Church, and then we can come back
I don't know the limitation
For going out there, but it seems to be dictated by water supply
which is gonna help us going out there, so the Party, wear dat
No , He qup(Equip) , ok Confirmed
Equp(Equip) CCoonfirmedd
AAAnd send party, ok.
Yep, go, have fun.
Don't DIE
That's the important thing, don't be like Spike
(Getting Harsh) Spike was a lesson to you all (You didn't feed him)
(Jump)Oh god, there is a rat in here, Get out of here(To the rat) oh-oh he run away
Ok, Ahmm, Barbra?
It appears to be rat, can you steal it for food i guess.
Can you actually, can you clean this shit up?
How do you clean?
(clicking intensifies)
OH boi(Boy).
Ok, Barbra, you have ff-oh-oh-oh Barbra-Barbra- Barbra
Accept transmision Ok.
(Not gonna need subtitles)
Ok, that's good.All' right finish what you were doing on the toilet , i- i'd- i'd guess.
(Happy) Yay Day 8
oh,shit, accept transmision, examine items.
Coffe beans,  a spring,  burned clothes and a plastic bottle.
(He's getting angry)You didn't get god-damn shit, Marie
And why are you in charge, i know you're bossy but's it okay.
Let DaviD do something.
(Jump)Al' right, accept transmision
(Yup...)
... might have some good lot h- I know(He does?)
It's been raining for a long time.
Ok.
What do we got?
Plank of wood, no nail(Nails?) Metal
Ugghk
Seeeds, hey, seeds. (Seeds:"Oh hi Mark")
Oh can i build like...
(MindBlown)
Oh i didn't know i can build like a farming, thing.that'd be incredibly useful.
HE He...he
Oh man, a mannequin arm.
OHHH boy, i'll be able to make a full mannequin in no time.
I can't wait to have a new-found friend(Like Wilson?)When all the rest of my family dies.
(Jump) ok so i don't have actually need anyone to do that, i just need to do it miself. all right.(Do what?)
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
God-damnit, no nails, no food.
(Sudden Realization)
Oh we're dying out here.
(Jump) Oh good thing i've got a pair of pliers.
FoR The IPLiers (Inhale) I'VgOT APAirOpLAIRSDHHH(A pair of pliers)-Hey that's fine
(Jump)UHhhh Petrol Can... that's good.
Wait that's a lot of petrol that's actually really good.
Ok, Butt- All'rit that's fine
That's a looot of stuff that we can have.
Al-Accept transmision.
Ohhhh
They got another one?ohhh, ok.
What do you got, (Inhale)Food Yess, ok.
Take the....ehm..i've got a lot of springs, i don't need them.Who needs burnt clothes?
Let's get the food in'ere'
A burnt out laptop (Thinking)Maybe some recyclable components.Ok we can do that.
A'll right, we got pretty much everything else that we need, ok,That's it
I think they're done they should be coming home pretty soon
Nope.
Wow, ok. Search out in the wasteland.
They finding a lot of stuff out there, i didn't think that they'd-(Attention Shifts)UHhhhhh
A family member has lost health this-sude-wais
Radiation poisoning, dehidration and malnourishment
What do you need?
Suffocating?!
Oh take out the god-damn-hmph-Why are you doing  the suit?!
How long have you been suffocating in that suit?
It's been Dayys, BarBra, com'on i know you're a robot right now but
You need to be Vocal and communicate with everybdoy.
All' right.
Wait does that just mean, wait a minute....
Oh- no. the- the filther is fine.
Waith, but there is no power.
Ohhhh that's what the problem is.
Oh shit' had no idea, oh shit, ok.
Wait.
Uhh...fix?
Oh god!
with-What are you doing?!?
Where are you going?!?
What are you doing?!
Fix the God-damn Thing
You, uhhhh, add fuel.
There we go, god-damnit, how long have been not doing that?
Ok, search the location, good Lordie
I proam- missed the transmission.
Oh god.
Okay
It's fine, allright, doahmmm...
Uhhhhh we have plenty of metal we can use these first  aid kits, considering
We Just SUFocated to Death.
We don't need a plastic bottle, but we do need....
These antibiotics would be good in case we get into any trouble.
Wiring.
We could use that....
(Inner Quasimodo emerges.)
Uaagghhh.
Aheemmmm
A'mn-full go at the coffe beans.I am get thee....
let's seee....
I'm-get the wiring cuz we don't have a lot of that, maybe it'will be good.
(Jump) Uph- Another one, god-damnit, how many things have they stumbled across, out there?
A'l right- you need to- oh we're out of food.
(¯\_(ツ)_/¯ )
Thh-that's bad.
That's bad, you're about to starve to death, kids, how about you eat that rat down there?
Oh, not, Ft-Steven.
I like Fteven
(You're_going_down.Wav)
Ohh jeez food.
Carrier Bag.
That could be useful in the future.
Scrappile, sand, not good for us.
I am get the bags so we can carry more shit, Later.
A'l- Guess that's it.
Get back home!
Fteven is starving!
Damn-it.
Oh man, we don't have enough, we  don't have enough, we  don't have enough ,we  don't have enough.
Ahh noh.
(Pretty much sum up the entire series so far.)
(we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough. we  don't have enough.)
Hope they get back soon.
They better get back here.
Ok, the showers could use some repairs.So fix the shower.
And you.
Let's see. how-how much fuel we doing?
We're completely out of-GET BackHERE, We need food.
Fteven needs food, it's burnt in the shower. (wat?)
Ok
We got dat, and that means
Take All
No room?. what do you mean there is no room?
God-damnit how much, aww man.
I'gotta make choices for this shit.
I-I think i need to salvage this stuff
Before i can do anything  before i can do anything, but i should have salvaged them way before.
Damn-it,Damn-it,Damn-it,Damn-it, Bag-Matic, diamont.
Ohhh, my god you're gonna die.
Ok
Forget the light-bulb, take the Med-kits, we need the anti-biotics so take out the...(Jump)
Ok, let's get rid of the empty ones for now
Let's take the...
"Denied"
Damn-it god damnit.  i need this bag.
Ok, i don't know
(Nice_Track_Avi)
Ahhhhhh forget the coaaall
Forget the coal for now.
Take the bags so we can get more in the future. Ok.
All right, it's all we can do, i need to get more storage, i need to build a lot more storage.
Steven stop what you're doing.
And Frickin Eat.
God-damnit.Stop
You assholes better not take that food from SFteven
Or DaviD
someone is at the intercoom?
Who?!
Who the-Who the hell are you?!Karen?
(You know the drill)
(Mildly threatening.)
Ok, hi karen, did you jumped over from Subnautica®?
What happened to you'r husband in the middle of nowhere, did you let him drown?
Probably.
Com' on in Karen
Welcome to the family
So she is another mouth to feed so we need.
To send people out on the expedition like, NOW.
Ok, so i am gonna send out-
SFteven
Karen, i thought, Karen.
Couldn't be sent out
Ok
So we're gonn-send out
BRaBRa
And SFTeven
Cuz, they need to go DO
Things
Ok, so they went to a lot of-
ohhhh, they must have swept across the other houses first.
Ok
There we go.
Nah, that's too much.
they can't  carry all that  shit.
so (So more single words...)
(Something) Back
Al- we need to...
No,no,no,no.
Let's just go...
Here
Or there, and there.
And that should cover enough.
And be good enough  for us.
Oh no....
Oh no...
One use only!?!
(Jump)
I just give a man a radia  tion tabblet.
That'd-That'd be good.That' i'll all set it....probably.
Yeah(Histerical)
He'll be fine!
FTeven will be fine, he is starving-anD-Tired.
aND-probably gonna be Laiden with radiation
But maybe he'll mutate into something useful, and we can actually
Utilize, in the future.
All'right Karen
The water filter is start-Starting to fall apart
(Sassy ) Well why don't you do something about it Davidd?
Oh, shit, don't do that.
You need a suit.
K, get a suit.
And go fix-Morn over the loss of Spike
And then do your thing.
Wait, we got a new diary enter.
(Halfway in. )
(C'mon you can do it)
(Hope you liked my subtitration....or whatever, i don't care. *Hope you like my fix on these subtitles*)
(I do)
(Getting Nervous) Oh- i bet not!
I bet it's filled with murder and (Familines?)
And badddd stuff like that.
(Jump)
...Probably just a wast
Gift-Distance, between things...(Attention shifts)
Okay!
Gas Mask,that's good...
Rock!
Ohh, boy!
(Caveman Mark emerges)
We can hit people with rock!
Anyone that come steal from us, get smashed with rock!
Man do Co dem!
Man do song!
Mamn Do Bang  them in the Head
Take wife, tak e food.
Take Fire!
(Jump)
Sorry i got a little t oo into that.
Well-p might have well have some nooses.
Metal ore...
Ok....
Oh, that's what i need to do, i need to recycle the stuff that we have right now
K-i know  that we have some of thooose...Ok.
So we're gonna-Ok so what we need to do-we to open the storage and we need to actually salvage this shit.
How do we salvage ?
Karen, can you salvage something?
Craft item.
Ehm...
Shit.
(Puzzled)How do we salvage?
That's a good question.
(Auto-ironic)Maybe i should try to learn how to play the god-damn game.
Probably not though -bha-bha-bha-Bh(jump)
All'ri-we need-oh we can build Mop n' Bucket.
That'd be nice cuz we don't exactly-(Attention shifts) Wow hiii- okkkk.
Sorry, you startled me.
That's a mop n' bucket- man there is not a lot of floor space over here.
(To the audience) We need somebody to dig more, later.
But that's later- so we'll get to that.
(Can you make a subscriber work for it?)
All'-You build a mop n' bucket so hopefully you'll keep this- ohh
(Whispering)Let's see.
Woah.
(Uh-uh....)
Get inv-I wanna get involved!
Oaaahhhhh- what's happening?
(Excited  Amazement)
Uhhhhh-what id'dis?
Hi, oh shit...
Well that's not good...
Were ar mi rock?
(So...you have a child, and an adult mother fighting a full grown bear...with rocks and sticks....)
Were am rock
Oh god!
Wait, ok....
Attack!
Uhhh...subdue, steal?!?
Steal from that Bear!
You better steal BarBra!
uhhh-how about you...subdue?
Giah
Oh shit, that ain't good.
(unintelligible)
Ohh my----(Girly Scream)
(More Girly Screams)
It's mauling-It's mauling BarBra
Uhhhg...attack?
Mele!
Ag hdra...Ohhhhh that's...
Ohhhh, good.
(Amazing, that kid it's beating the shit out of the bear)
Wowww!Stewen with the combo...
All'right-Baaam
Woah, holly shit!
BarBara
You're a beast!
(Even more  girly screams)
Sthewen!
(chuckling)("M'Lady")Don't hit his fedora
(Unintelligible, again)
All-right, Melle!
Puf, Bammp, Baauhhh, Auu (Is this what do i have to deal with??)
Ok that's nice, that's cool too.
Byarrr
OOOooookkk
wow , this ain't good.
Auuu
(more auuu)
(Basic human emotion showing of fear and approaching death)
Piffff
Baaam
Kabuff
(Chuckling) Huhu, man Stewen, you're a brave little kid.
I've got admit this is kinda funny
(Fedora man-child wins)
Ohhh, dead.
All right-welp, killed that bear with my bare hands.
(Inhale)
Bear Meat!
Niiiiiceeee
Niiiiceeee
Okkkkkk, that's good.
Woooooohhhh
All right
Besides the "minor" Bear wound that we suffered
Maybe we'll get a bottle of bear ointment (is that a thing?) while we're out here.
Cover em' up with bear bandages
I will be bearely allive
(kill meehh)
Well that was my first battle, i didn't even know there was a battle sistem in this game
all'right, clean shelter please.
Karen, pull you'r weight, clean the god-damn shelter.
Can you kill that bunneh(Bunny)?
(Attempt at communicating something)
Who the fuck are you?ok, search that
Who the fuck are you, Gregory?!
You better not come in here because we don't have enough food for everybody
Oh, god-damnit.
We don't have enough. We can't do it, just can't do it-Ok.
Tier 2....
Satchel...that would be nooiiicee
Trip-wire....
Bed-roll....
Carrier bag...Bandages to stop bleeding
I'ma-I have a funny felling we're gonna need those.
Cuz' i am pretty sure SFTeven is still Bleeding.
What are you doing there?!
Go away Gregory!
Hang on.
Yup...ohhh, Passion Flower?!
ahhh, i don't know if we need that, what did you find?
Wait, where did they go i didn't even re-(Gregory is getting impatient)
I am sorry, Gregory i'll be right with you, we don't have, we can't, can't do it, sorry.Can't do it.
Ok...(Gregory is getting pissed) Sorry.
We need to get rid of some shelter stuff before they come back.
Gregory!
(Pleading for safety)
(Fuck off, he says)
Gregory i am sorry.
We're at full capacity, we got no frickin Foood
Sorryy.
Goodbyee!
Am i gonna watch this guy get brutally murdered?Probably.
We got some food on the way, but we don't have any way to cook it.
I-I don't know how to cook it.
So any way- we can craft like ahh....
Like a stowe or something?...
An incinerator...
Stable...
Oh that would have been nice...
Oh that would have been real nice for Spike if'd had know about that
(Confidence)
Ahhh poor stowe, a hiinnge?!
How the fuck do you get a Hinge?!
Aww man...
Ahhhh, shit.
(Wikipedia time)
Oh god, i just found out, the-The term is Recycling, not salvaging and you need to build a recycling  "plant"
To do that, and it take 4 in-game hours to do something
So can't even recycle these, i don't even need these things in my thing to recycle i can't do anything about em'
Yet, so i need keep getting new stuff, and hopefully.
I don't know how but i need to get hinges so that i can get stuff in order
And i probably have seen hinges before, i just didn't know that was something that i needed
Ohhhhh, they're gonna Starve(Again)
Were they-Where-Where are the guys?
Where is the rest of my family?
(Getting Worried)
Was it- Oh there they are
Ohhh, noo....
Ohhhh....
Kill that Elk!
Kill it, kill the weird Skull face Elh(Elk)
(Uninteligible)
Kill it!
Ahhh, shit.
Sftewen ain't felling so good, because i believe
That SFteven is bleeding
Take alll.
I don't know, those are the things that we need, i am not  gonna leave those behind
Ok, so....
(Decision Making in process)
Ohhh, i don't any freezers for the meat?!
Awww, mannn....
We just have honey and you can't eat that...
God-damnit, are you....
Let me-Let me just see...
Nope, you need a freezer for it... i didn't know that
(Stressed out)
SSSSSsssson, of a bitch.
Fuk
Well...shit... we got .....no..... fuckin...... food.
So what we need to do...We need to send people out like.... Okay-First, Sfteven you need to take Bandages...
And fix yourself up, cuz i know that you're bleeding, Lady, are you bleeding?OK.
We need to set-up another expedition, with DaviD ....and Marie
But Marie is hungry, she's probably going to starve on the way out there
We just need to...
We just gotta go to this things again...
(Realization)
Oh shit we don't have enough Water
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
Really?
Ohhh noeeee...
Ohhh nooo, we are FFUuuuuuCKeed
(Clicking intensifies)
Oh we're fuckeeddddd.
Ohhhhh we're fucckeeddd.....
(Same shit as before)
(Markiplier pleads for help)
(Gabe Newell intervene)
(Praise Lord Gabe Newell)
We got water!
Hurray, we can do an ex-pedition
Everyone is gonna(Not going to) starve
YYaaahhhhh
Woooaahhh Booiii (Boy)
Well, here we go...
Set an expedition, i guess...
Ohhhh, boy, they're gonna die, we're gonna die in'ere and they're gonna die out there, everyone is gonna die.
Ahhhh this is not looking good...
It's not looking goooooddddd.
Man when i wanted to come back in the series.
I told you guys...
It' wasn't gonna be good.
Mhhhhhh, not gonna be good.
Ohhh, man...
(Life is hard)
I know they're malnourished...
I knoooowwww...
Oh, they want to talk, aaahhh ok, let's talk to them, considering we're about to die anyway
That's a good option...
Hello, Hii stranger!
Ohhhhhh
(Basic Human Interaction)
I don't have anything.
All right, goodbye.
Awww damn i thought it was going to be my lucky day.   ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Maybe next time, okkkk....
Good enough.
Goodbyee, nice hangin man in the background.
All, right, what do you got-Ahhh food.
One-One piece of Food.
Better than nothing.
Beeether that nothing.
You know that's interesting, the music in this game reminds me of...
....It's the weirdest connection, reminds me of Deux-Ex® The original one.
Like the very first Deux-Ex® that ever come out-or Deus Ex® or whatever you want to call it...
The music in there was like some electronic-techno, supposed to be futuristic and stuff
Because the game took place way in the future.
And I-For some reason... i am getting those vibes from it, i don't know why.
Kinda cool, i like it, i dig it.
One more food, just one, We're crawling by, we're not gonna have enough food, but we're crawling by.
I don't think they're gonna be back before...
Everyone dies...
Approach strangers, ohh boy, i didn't even read that was-Small Pharmacy, approach strangers
This is gonna end well.
Hiiii, woah...
(Uninteligible)
Hello
Confirmed
Bully?
Bully!?
Heeeyyyy
(mistakes were made)
Oh, shit, that's not what i wanted ahh, shit.
Ahhhhh
welp
(Savage Marpkiplier) Me am hit with rock.
Me am hit Marie With Marie.
(Inception)
Marie V Marie.
Only one Marie Lives...
Two Marie (Unintelligible)
Only one Marie Lives.(Again)
Mele
EEEhhhhh
With Rock!
Me am hit you with Rock
You can't whitstand all rocks
Like father like son(He forgot his daughter sex too)
Ohh, shit.
Like father, like son, we fail.
Auuu
(Pain)
(Even more pain)
Man, that Marie doesn't like the other Marie, i don't know how you caused it to (Unintelligible) but
I don't....like it....
Kabowww
Oh man, Marie, killed Marie.
Marie cut Marie out...
Wowww, ok.
that was....ridiculous.
Yeah, Marie.
You level up
A little more Trauma, but not much for a little girl, she's used to Murder.
Ohoh, we got strangers again.
Marie is still bleeding so i hope it doesn't turn to violence.
Hello.
Hi
PaMelà
uhhh, trade?
Wat?
I just want-what are you talking about?
I just wanted to trade...
K, never mind then.
You-you have lovely day now
I don't know....
I don't know what the hell happened there.
I don't know what the hell- I didn't hav-you didn't have anything i wanted
awww, one more can of Food. But
This is not looking good.
I mean that's one can of food for everybody, technically
I just don't know if the're gona get back in time before...
("At least i tried" face)
The inevitable, happenn.GBBBHHHGGH
Ohh, one nail, i need a nail,uhhh a knife that would be cool
Sand, we don't need that.
Okay, we're done.
Let's me just check storage again, to see if there is anything else i can dump
Before they get back
I mean i gue-I guess i can dump fuel....
(Jump)
Are they comin' back?This must be the return trip
they must be coming back, pretty soon.
Ohhhh, it's not going to be soon enough!
Ohhhhh it's not gonna be soon enough.
Ohhhhhh it's not gonna be- OHH
C'mon, c'mon,c'mon,c'mon, Go,Go,Go
UHHHHH (Mildly excited)
Food food food!
Take the food, take the food, get the food, YISSSS
Yiiisssss
Ok, they got it.
We don't have the knife but that's ok.
(Caveman Mark) We have-got ROCK!
We am-get Rock
We no need rock
We don't need the honey either, let's the knife.
(Somewhat intelligent Caveman) Knife better than rock
We'the Iplliers don't need mppfhhh Rock no more...
Rock are (Unintelligible)
(Still Unintelligible)
Ok, Eat, eat, for the love of goodness gracious, EaT right NOW!
No, no, you eat-eat food.
You too.
Do not-don't go over there.
I am not staying here to take this kind of abuse i better-
Goodbye, Great! that leaves one extra food.That is soo goodd.
Ohhh that's soo good.
Ahhhhh, Yeess
The Ipliers have survived!
(For now)
Good bye, Karen!
We didn't need you anyway- it wasn't gonna be good- we weren't bonding
I mean you didn't even mourn over the dead corpse of our Horse ,Spike.
I mean, we are assholes but, c'mon!
C'mooon
You mean how we hunted them and then murdered  them and then took their stuffff?
Probably.
Ok
So there are quest too eh?
Wait, wasn't Marie Bleeding?
or did she take care of that i guess...
how abut you use the first aid pack?
You too, use the first aid, Jez.
How about DaviD?
DaviD is allright, Marie is allright, SfTeven is about to get all right.
Ookkkkk
OOOOKKKKKK
OOOKKKKK
We're doing OK!
I am shocked, which, wow that was really close, but we made it through
I know that we need to Expedite More
To the recent locations
And...
We need to get more food.
Food is priority, we cannot survive without food as it's obvious, but...
Awwww, man i don't know how much longer we re gonna be able to survive, but for right now we're doing GREAT!
So THANK YOU everybody, so much, for watching
Let me know if you wanna se even more of this
i wouldn't mind starting a new series of this game
it's really fun
There is something really inteeresting about the Omen of survival
That people really...Like....Identify with, like, i love this.
That's why people love zombie appocalipse so much because they love the struggle, like, the drama of it, like,the-the dire situations are really fun
So- i mean not fun to them,but me!As the Overlord, controlling all of them, they're gonna be fine with me.
So THANK YOU EVERYBODY SO MUCH FOR WATCHING(Again)
And as always
I will see you...
In the next Video
BAH BYEEE!
(Ohh)
(It's Over?!?)
(Took me 2 days to finish this subtitles. *Hey you did good. I just fixed some things. ^_^*)
(But as long as this brings a smile to one person lips, it'll be worth it. *well you did it!*)
(Have a good day! *Love you Markiplier!*)